I think there should both be a cabinet
level agency or office and then you know
an agency underneath that there's just
too much going on right now to expect
that all the existing agencies have it
covered they kind of wrote a memo kind
of saying that in in between the lines
but the reality is that the existing
laws don't anticipate certain things
like we have laws about protecting
private individual speech but what do
you do if somebody makes a billion
pieces of harmful misinformation a day
we don't have laws for that just to give
you one example AI makes things possible
in a wholesale way where they could only
be possible retail before it's sort of
similar to like a submachine gun versus
a knife you have to think about them
differently
[Music]
um
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast one of the foremost AI experts
in the world he recently testified the
U.S Senate also sold an AI company to
Uber has a doctorate from MIT one of the
champions for Humanity when it comes to
AI Gary Marcus welcome Gary thanks for
having me man yeah so you've been on the
AI train for a long time uh when did you
start dipping your toes in I was kind of
boring on the train I I the first time I
really thought about AI I was eight
years old and I went through a kind of
gifted and talented after school program
and my teacher who I'm still friends
with put a paper computer in front of me
which basically worked the way in
Assembly Language microprocessor would
work very low level instructions and
taught me how to use it and that very
day was my first media appearance
because the local news people filmed me
explaining how this thing worked for
like a human interest story I've been
thinking about AI pretty much ever since
like how do you get computers to do
interesting things when I was a kid it
was like how do you get them to play
games I was you know an only child and
always in need of extra companions and
and started fooling around with
programming machines to play Tic-tac-toe
and stuff like that and then when I was
in high school I programmed a system to
translate Latin into English and um I
don't know if you know this about me but
I'm a high school dropout and the way
that I managed to pull that off was I
submitted the AI that I had written as a
sample of work and went to college early
after 10th grade so I never finished
high school and AI was kind of my ticket
off to college so worked out for me then
so you showed up at College sounds like
the age six age 16 or so did you race
through the rest of your education I did
I did College in three years partly
because I didn't really have money for
four
um and partly because I was just kind of
done and then I did uh MIT and four got
my PhD and then
I was an assistant professor when I was
23 years old I remember when I arrived I
was teaching at UMass Amherst they did a
histogram to plot the ages of all the
faculty most of them were like in their
40s somewhere in their 50s they're all
kind of higher during the baby boom and
I was this lone dot all the way on the
left that was the one 23 year old next
closest was like 27 or 28. so I'm not
that young anymore but there was a time
when I was pretty young to be a
professor uh and you grew up in New
England I grew up in Baltimore and then
moved to New England for college and
grad school and that first faculty job
so I I spent a lot of time in Baltimore
and then a lot of time in Massachusetts
and then New York and then most recently
I moved to Vancouver all right so you're
the youngest Professor around that must
have been a little weird it was pretty
weird I couldn't figure out who to date
it was it was it was awkward so how did
what were your next steps uh after you
were an Android professor at UMass I was
an adjunct I was an assistant professor
I was Tang your track
um after that I moved to NYU in 97 and I
was the associate professor without
Tanger then I became tenure Professor
full Professor I did a kind of whole
academic life and then started a company
and basically didn't really go back to
the academy after that I did a whole
academic life and on things that are
very relevant now so my
dissertation was on how children learn
language so part of it was like human
psychology but part of it was looking at
neural networks that are very much the
predecessor of this stuff that like
large language models are built on and
so I started thinking about these
questions of like do you need abstract
rules can you do everything with neural
networks where do neural networks make
mistakes as part of my dissertation that
I did at MIT Steve Pinker was my mentor
and then continued on with that stuff
not so much working in a mostly working
on human cognitive psychology how does
the human mind work how do kids manage
to learn language when machines aren't
very good at it questions like that and
then they return to AI in 2011 because I
made a mistake I almost never make
mistakes in science I think I'm my
predictions are usually right so when I
get one wrong I wake up and I'm I
predicted that Watson would lose in
Jeopardy I thought well language is
complicated you know how are they going
to pull this off and so I was wrong it
turns out there's a trick to how they
won but it's also very interesting I
talk about that in my own podcast humans
versus machines we have Ken Jennings who
lost to Watson and David ferrucci who
built it but when ferucci won and beat
Ken Jennings I was like hey maybe AI is
getting interesting again and I've been
in the field ever since over the last
decade the trick is that 95 or 99 of the
answers in uh
Watson turn out to be titles of
Wikipedia pages so it doesn't have to do
as much inference and reasoning and
stuff like that as you might think but
it was still interesting enough to get
me back in the field and when I returned
to the field neural networks started
getting popular again and I was like I
know about that stuff I wrote a book
about them in 2001 which actually
anticipated the hallucination problem
that they have so much right now where
they make stuff up you know I thought
about all this stuff a long time ago and
suddenly it became very relevant again
yeah so how do you go from being this
distinguished Professor doing a research
to starting an AI company that's an
interesting question I was actually
inspired by Dennis hassebis over a deep
mine when when they sold their company
for ton of money and they were not
primarily a product focused firm they
were really about developing ideas for
AI and research ideas and I thought I
could do that and I had a friend who's
one of the best people in machine
learning zubeen garamani who had gone to
grad school and I said hey maybe we
should start a company too like we could
get gather a bunch of smart people come
up with new ideas and you know if we
don't have to like sell widgets and just
you know if there's space in in the AL
world for just coming up with better
algorithms and stuff like that we can do
that and we did and we were only in
business for two years and all kinds of
companies came to us and wanted to buy
us and you know Uber made us what seemed
at the time to be a pretty good deal and
we took it and so it was I had been
writing at that point a lot about AI I
wrote
one paper that I think was particularly
important in 2012 in the New York or an
essay about why deep learning had limits
and why even though there was a lot of
excitement it still had trouble with
causal reasoning and abstraction and so
forth and I was like I'm giving my ideas
away to the New Yorker for 250 an essay
and that one really foresaw the tension
that we've had in the next decade in AI
I was like I'm doing this but I could I
could probably do that too and and it
took me a little while my wife persuaded
me she said it's a good idea you should
really do this you should take the
plunge she came from a family of
entrepreneurs I I did not come from a
family of entrepreneurs I was like all
right I I recruited some friends and and
it worked out really well so fast
forward to today you are testifying the
U.S Senate as to the pitfalls around AI
what did you say to them and what do you
think the that the news accounts are
getting right and wrong not not of your
testimony but just generally where is
concerned it might be worth filling in
something there so
um you know I gave you a sort of story
of my research career mentioned that I
did some entrepreneurial work but I
really in the last several months moved
hard into policy I thought about policy
before
um I had actually proposed a CERN for AI
in 2017 which is an idea that UK has
been picking up on lately
um
so I thought about policy before but I
was still kind of more in the academic
world and what I saw really around when
being in Bard came out in February was a
sudden acceleration on the part of the
tech companies that felt irresponsible
to me and that's really what shifted me
and how I wound up testifying the Senate
it already been writing a lot about the
Perils of misinformation and saying like
we need to take seriously even if these
machines aren't very smart I really
think they're not very sophisticated
they can still do a lot of harm and so I
started writing a lot about that and
that was really what led me to the
Senate is I started to make the case
that we need some regulation I had a TED
Talk in April and I made that about
having a global
um an international Agency for AI and so
I started really getting concerned they
were racing very quickly
Without Really knowing how to control
these systems and that that caused a lot
of dangers both short-term and long term
maybe we can get into that
um and I think made it clear and
articulate case and that's how I wound
up testifying in the Senate so there's a
little bit of background so so people
ask me sometimes about the potential
short-term dangers and I I said well
let's see you could have a
uh
an erosion of truth because you have a
thousand different versions of reality
and deep fake videos and and audio
recordings and what have you you could
have rampant identity theft because of
the fact that my wife can call me and
ask me to do something but it's not my
wife
there have been real cases of that right
there there have been people who for
example got called saying their kids
were kidnapped and then they wired money
you know Bitcoin to people who are
really scam artists so this is actually
happening with the The Voice faking
stuff so so the so these are the some of
the negative scenarios that I've
described that I find totally
plausible not even plausible near
certain because you have these tools and
then guess what human nature is what it
is and so you might have people putting
out videos and deep fakes for various
purposes uh certainly the identity theft
I mean that's just for commercial gain
where you think ooh like that there's a
way I can I can get some money in a way
that can't be traced to me effectively
so those are the obvious ones but there
are also some in obvious ones yeah
there's a lot so I mean first of all
I'll say that the threat to democracy is
the one that worries me the most like I
just don't see how the 2024 election
isn't going to be a show there's
going to be so much use of these tools
um and again we can see a lot of October
surprises you know fake stories about
this or that candidate having a heart
attack or whatever
um there's gonna be a ton of that and
these new tools make it cheaper to make
misinformation they allow people to make
it wholesale rather than retail like
it's as much larger quantities and very
convincing and we've never confronted
that before so that's actually my
biggest fear and that you know my shift
in policy started with misinformation as
my biggest concern and it remains my
biggest concern but there are others
like there was a line that I said in my
Senate testimony which is people will
use these tools to manipulate our um
elections and our markets and I didn't
have a good example this was only a few
weeks ago in May I didn't have a good
example of the manipulation of markets
and then like a week after I testified
there was this fake picture of the
Pentagon on fire and that did actually
move the markets I don't know if it was
on purpose I don't know why people did
it but surely that sent a sign to other
people hey we could make money shorting
the market by putting out misinformation
so we're going to see that that's
another kind of risk we're going to see
lots of romance scams basically
automated where people use these tools
to you know do 100 000 Romancing or
billion you know romance scams at once
so you see a lot of that kind of cyber
crime and that's just short term longer
term I think there other concerns so I
don't worry so much about Extinction I
didn't sign the famous Extinction letter
like it's really hard to extinguish the
human species like literally get rid of
absolutely everybody
um but there are a lot of really serious
things like you could have accidental
nuclear war either caused by
misinformation or by market manipulation
that leads to people to be suspicious of
other people that didn't actually do
things and they get mad and there's
escalation
there's a lot of very serious risks
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been a mattress guy because
it was common sense to me you spend up
to eight hours a day sleeping more if
you're lucky and so the right mattress
can make a huge difference what the heck
does it mean for something to be the
right mattress for you you can take the
Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes sent to
your door you know they believe in their
product because they offer a 100 night
trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty to
try out your new mattress I endorse this
mattress because I literally sleep on it
and so do my kids there are a couple
mattresses in the house and this is the
one that they seek out even though it
was made for me it's so good that even
my kids are like hey they feel like it's
made for them but it's not it's a number
one mattress picked by GQ and wired and
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep keep
Starts Now
[Music]
own warranted military conflict makes my
risk list as well
and you've called for some kind of
international body uh which I I agree
with when I was running for president I
pitched a world data organization that
was pitched to me by Ian bremmer who
just had a TED Talk that I know you saw
we actually met at Ted I'll let you
finish your story but a quick anecdote
about Ian is we met at lunch the day
before I gave my TED Talk and he said
what's your Ted talk about and I said
well imagine you're at a 60s protesting
you say what do you want or what do we
want International governance for AI
when do we want it now and he interns to
me and says six months ago his Ted Talk
was on a similar uh topic as you know
it's so fun to imagine the two of you
guys hanging out in Vancouver together
uh that that's that makes me happy uh
you know had fun there and then we met
in New York a few weeks ago so you know
we we've only met a few times but all
all recently and we're starting to
um really click together
I I can see that uh you know I like and
admire both of you
um uh and uh humanity is better for
having the two of you connected thank
you so uh so an international body
um I I I've called for uh something I'm
not sure if you included in your Senate
testimony which is uh an AI dedicated or
regulatory body here in the U.S what do
you think about that idea yeah I think
absolutely I mean I think there should
both be a cabinet level agency or office
and then you know an agency underneath
that there's just too much going on
right now to expect that all the
existing agencies have it covered they
kind of wrote a memo kind of saying that
in in between the lines but the reality
is that the existing laws don't
anticipate certain things like we have
laws about protecting private individual
speech but what do you do if somebody
makes a billion pieces of harmful
misinformation a day we don't have laws
for that just to give you one example AI
makes things possible in a wholesale way
where they could only be possible retail
before it's sort of similar to like a
submachine gun versus a knife you have
to think about them differently so there
are a lot of new both opportunities we
want to take advantage of and a lot of
risks that we need to look out for I
think we need somebody in the White
House whose job is full-time think about
this and nothing else and they need to
staff to keep up with all of the
different parameters of it and this is
not to like cut out existing agencies
from the loop but we're going to need
some new things so for example I think
that we want to have something like FDA
approval if somebody's going to do
research that's one thing but if they're
going to roll out a system to a hundred
thousand people or sorry 100 million
people
um you know we really want to test it
make sure it's safe in the same way we
do with a drug we don't just say I did
you know trials on 10 people okay let's
put it out to every drugstore on the
planet we say let's show that you know
this is right and we need independent
examiners to say you've made this case
but there are weaknesses in your case we
need to understand this better you say
that there's this risk you don't have
anything about the risk we also need an
agency to push the companies to be
transparent you have Microsoft saying
transparency is important to us and then
they use gpt4 and we don't know what's
inside of gpt4 we don't know what it's
trained on which has a huge influence on
things like bias so we need someone to
really hold the company's feet to the
fire so I am a hundred percent for
having an agency like that and I've been
talking to people in Washington and
trying to talk up that idea as much as I
can yeah so after you went uh to the
Senate your testimony was very warmly
received what do you see as the
prospects for some of your
recommendations being followed or
a coherent regulatory approach I like
the word coherent that is that is the
the nub of it um on the one hand I'm
very inspired in certain ways so the
hearings that I was at hearing was one
of the most bipartisan things I think
the Senate has done in a long time and I
think everyone I know who kind of
follows Washington more closely than I
do was amazed at how Cooperative it was
how much people recognized the urgency
genuinely seem to want to work together
seem to
um
recognize that with social media they
didn't quite get things right and and
you know want to move quicker and better
so you have that on the positive side of
The Ledger on the negative side of The
Ledger it sort of feels like everybody
in Washington has their own ideas about
what to do and they're not necessarily
all coordinated and talking to each
other and I wouldn't say there's any one
clear answer that has emerged yet
um and so like there's a lot of
motion but whether that motion turns out
to be coherent I think is the question
there's one moment I liked in the Senate
proceedings which was a kind of
recognition of their own limitations I
can't remember who was that said it but
they said look we're not here to
legislate like the day-to-day the way I
would repeat it is the Senate shouldn't
be there to make rules for gpt5 as
opposed to gpt4 the Senate should be
there to create an enduring agency that
can move with the flow and follow all of
the details and I think you know some of
them realize that they don't want to be
micromanaging the details of AI
development if they get it right they
will build some agency that is Nimble
enough fast enough to be able to deal
with things as they move yeah that that
the last thing you'd want is a senate
have to check in anytime is a new
development
they don't want that you don't want them
to do that right I mean with due respect
I mean some of the Senators are really
following what's going on like I saw
Senator Blumenthal on a call after the
um proceedings and he really understands
all of the issues he's following very
closely but you can't expect 100
Senators to all you know have their
fingers on on the pulse of AI they might
like right now because they're going to
make a first important decision but you
know certainly in the long term they
have so many other things to focus on
and so that they shouldn't be
micromaging
foreign
some things we do in public some things
we do in private and we certainly would
like to be able to know that when we're
alone we're actually getting our privacy
online is the same thing your online
privacy is just as important as in the
real world that's why I use expressvpn
when I'm online because I don't want my
internet service provider to know every
website I visit nor do I want them to
sell my data to Big tech companies
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
connection a tunnel between your device
and the internet no one can see it it
works on any device all you have to do
is fire up the expressvpn app click one
button it's as easy as that I recommend
this Fortune 500 companies use
expressvpn for good reason and you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
free by going to expressvpn.com Yang
that's
expressvpn.com Yang for three extra
months free 3. expressvpn.com yang
foreign
so we're frightening people a little bit
what are some of the
positive use cases and applications of
AI you see coming down the pike one of
the ones that I cite is look I think
we're going to have some very powerful
new
Therapeutics individualized and
otherwise to treat some previously
untreatable conditions I think that's
right I think I mean one of the reasons
I'm in AI is because I think it has the
potential to really Advance Science and
Technology if you think about
biology our bodies have you know hundred
thousand different proteins in them and
any kind of new drug that you make is a
matter of kind of three-dimensional
chemistry molecules have to fit together
in exactly the right way and it's very
complicated for any individual human to
understand it all and so in principle if
you had an AI system that could causally
understand the world the way a scientist
does but do the computation that a big
computer can do you'd be able to
simulate things and figure out stuff
that no human has ever been able to do
and in that way really I think
fundamentally Advanced science we can't
do that with the technology we have now
but I think that there's you know hope
that we will get there and there's so
many diseases where we've made almost no
progress like Alzheimer's for example
let's hope that we might eventually be
in progress there yeah so those are some
of the things to be excited about one of
the
species level of concerns you see out
there you're dubious of which is that
you're going to have a super
intelligence that uh gets to a point
where it doesn't see a need for us some
people refer to this as AGI or
artificial general intelligence uh I
think this is a level above even what
you're describing in terms of a machine
that's able to reason
and your dubious that AGI is anytime on
the near-term horizon so I don't think
artificial general intelligence AGI is
imminent but I think it's possible the
intelligence that we have right now
can't really reason can't stick to facts
it does what we call hallucinations make
stuff up all the time real artificial
intelligence or AGI is not going to do
that stuff it will actually be able to
reason you'll be able to keep track of
the world it won't invent stuff
arbitrarily that might be a decade away
it might be two decades away I think
it'll happen this Century but we're not
that close to it now even if you had it
we don't necessarily face Extinction
risk it doesn't follow like night
follows day that if you have a smart
machine that we're in Jeopardy none of
the machines that we've ever built are
particularly interested in human
territory for example you know go has
got the machine go has gotten much
better but
the systems aren't fighting us for
territory things like that
um it doesn't go around killing all the
go players it doesn't go around killing
all the go players it doesn't even know
that there are go players right it just
knows about this board it's a real
speculation to say that machines are
ever going to have any interest uh in US
in that sense I wouldn't say it's
impossible Jeff Hinton said it's not
inconceivable and I think that's right
but I think what we should really be
worried about is what are Bad actors
going to do with these Technologies you
know we know we have bad humans that
want to seize territory enslave people
or whatever and so we should be watching
out for what people want to do with
these machines and not worrying so much
about like the Skynet scenario we should
have some people thinking about it I'm
not saying we should dismiss it all
together but I don't think it's our
immediate worry Kai Fu Lee came out with
a book a year or so ago maybe even more
now actually it's a few years old now ai
superpowers about China and the US
competing on AI he suggested that China
had a couple low structural advantages
in terms of access to more data because
it's kind of a top-down environment not
a lot of privacy
over there and so they could
crunch numbers at
higher orders of magnitude come up with
better algorithms and that was they also
had support from the government on a
scale that the U.S does not so those
were two structural advantages he cited
for China there is some anxiety that if
um one country or another develops uh
superiority in AI that this could be
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
which you're starting to see you're
starting to see some of the
repercussions in the stock market just
for fun because you've been in the space
for a long time did you buy Nvidia stock
a little while ago because I will say I
did not I did not I should have I've
been impressed with Jensen for a long
time and I should have
uh yeah I mean you'd have your sense of
what the heck is coming more so than
just about anyone
um but you're seeing something like
Nvidia get hundreds of billions of
dollars because now they're regarded as
the core
chip manufacturer for uh developing AI
let me lay a stat on you and then I'll
come back to the kaifu stuff
um Microsoft just put out a stock
analysis I forget what we call it
um
the forecast they they predicted that uh
gpt4 and so forth large language models
would add about 10 billion dollars a
year to their revenue
and like that's a lot of money you know
to me or you but to them it's not
actually that much money the people
making the most money off the AI
Revolution right now are the chip
manufacturers are really one it's Jensen
uh at Nvidia
um making money off the dream that this
stuff is going to affect the world but
so far large language models although
they're extremely popular have not
actually led to that much material
Revenue people are using them to program
computers there's money in that but
there's not an enormous amount they're
using it for search engine optimization
there's a lot of experimenting but it's
not clear how much money there is in a
technology that's fundamentally
unreliable it's interesting JPMorgan has
banned consumer-facing use of chat Bots
Apple just did the same like some of the
big companies are waking up to the fact
that even though this AI has been really
hyped it doesn't necessarily work that
well so how much revenue there actually
comes is not clear and then link I'll go
back to kaifuli
um
kaifu is certainly right that there is a
race on to get to AI or artificial
general intelligence I don't think we're
actually that close there's a lot of
worry over here that if we um you know
allow China to get to GPT 5 before us
that somehow the world will change in
radical ways that I think is silly you
know gbt5 will be better than gpt4 it
will write better boilerplate text but
it's not going to invent Interstellar
travel or you know redefine reality in
some fundamental way if China did get to
gpt5 six months before the United States
it's not clear it would have that much
consequence it probably raised their GDP
a little which they could kind of use
right now they're struggling a little
bit
um but it's not going to fundamentally
change science here's an example I give
gpt4
sees a lot of games of Chess in its
database it sees the rules of Chess and
it still does things like have Bishops
jump over Rooks like it does not
understand chess if you want to have a
system doesn't understand chess now
design a spaceship for you good luck
it's not really going to work like
people are attributing a kind of general
intelligence to these systems that they
don't really have so somebody may
eventually win the race to AGI but
nobody is close so it's not the
immediate concern that I think a lot of
people in both Nations think that it is
and you know there are now battles over
chips and and Export controls and stuff
like that I think partly premised on the
idea that GPT 5 is going to be this
magical thing it's not really I wrote
this um essay called What to Expect When
You're Expecting gpt4 around Christmas
before GPT 4 came out and I said
people's minds are going to be blown but
as they dig in they're going to realize
that it's still flawed that it still
hallucinates that it still doesn't
understand in the world
Etc and all of these predictions I had
seven predictions they were all correct
and they boiled down in some ways saying
four will be better
but it's not going to be magic the way
the people initially think that it is
same thing's going to happen with five
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
let's return to what you described as
the commercial use cases the revenue so
a month or two ago I wrote about how
Chegg the essentially you could call
Textbook and learning Tool company they
started out in textbooks reported that
students aren't using them as much they
think because they're using
gpt4 and who's asking them questions and
then they're going to answer so why
would you need to subscribe to check and
go through Cliff's Notes and all this
other stuff their stock then plummeted
uh overnight I think they lost a billion
in stock value than before getting at
least some of it back and I looked at
that and said wow you can easily see
Chad gbt eating that company's lunch
um I get the sense that there is a lot
of companies who are going to feel like
they have to use it and it may or may
not increase their revenues in that way
uh it's a little bit like um like a cost
of doing business I think uh or at least
for that some of these large corporates
will adopt
um there will be some Revenue in in that
but maybe not hundreds of billions to
your point the hype around it certainly
uh is massive when it comes to these
companies getting bit up in the
marketplace and you're suggesting that
that's a bit premature I mean you know
all of this is speculation nobody knows
for sure I will say in in defense of my
personal track record that in 2016 I
said everybody's putting money in
driverless cars and I don't think
they're going to work anytime soon I
said look the fundamental problem with
driverless cars is outliers you have
weird circumstances that aren't in your
data set you have systems that don't
really understand the world and so when
they get to these words weird
circumstances they don't know what to do
so I projected in 2016 that this was
going to be rough and nobody listened to
me and basically 100 billion dollars
more was invested in driverless cars
since I said that it hasn't led to that
much and you're going to have the same
kind of question question every domain
which is you got a demo here but what
does it take to make the demo into a
product and the answer is going to be
different in every domain because it's
going to depend on questions like yeah
what is the cost of error if you make a
medical advisor you know a single error
could be a malpractice suit that takes
down your company if you are
recommending computer code and debugger
I mean programmers know how to debug
they can just fix an error and there's
not going to be a malpractice suit and
it's fine so each domain is going to be
a little bit different in terms of how
good is using a system that doesn't
really understand what's going on but
can Pastiche together a lot of similar
text and be maybe like 80 correct some
places that'll be good enough and there
will really will be Revenue in some
places it won't it will get stuck in the
way that we have with driverless cars
where you know you need to be
99.9999
accurate and we just don't have the
technology for that yet yeah you have to
be able to accept uh let's call it in
one to five percent error rate which if
you're having AI write you a press
release really quick that you can edit
then you don't care it's like oh that
paragraph screwed up whatever
um but then if it's something that's
life or death then it's unacceptable it
does so what do you see so you've made a
very convincing case for the fact that
look some of these limitations are baked
because it doesn't have true
comprehension uh it's
um recognizing patterns it's
regurgitating things that seem coherent
and then sometimes you when you press on
them may or may not make sense so what
do you see as some domains where this
thing is going to uh to run I guess
we've described a couple of them which
are environments where you don't care if
it screws up one to five percent of the
time I think the best use case is
computer programming because not
everybody in the world understands how
to debug but everybody who becomes a
professional computer programmer does
because it's just too much Agony if you
don't have the right kind of mind to do
the troubleshooting in the logic so by
the time you're a professional
programmer you really know how to take
your own code which sometimes has
mistakes and figure out those mistakes
you have the logic of debugging and so
for you to have something that can write
the same code you could make the same
mistakes you did maybe some slightly
different ones but you know how to do
that as a professional coder it's great
saves coders a ton of time it's probably
going to drive out some of the
outsourced companies you know it's a
problem when you have people from
another country write code for you and
you don't quite agree on what you want
and so you wind up fixing that stuff
that kind of Outsourcing stuff probably
people are going to lose jobs but
programmers can make use of bad code
that's just part of what they do for a
living is to take bad code and make it
better that's the debugging process so
that still seems to me like the single
best use case the other really great use
case
um not from a moral sense is writing
basically text for search engine
optimization so one of the biggest uses
of at least of gbt3 there's a company
called Jasper and a lot of what they do
is basically write blog entries I think
to help people who you know promote
their products
um in search engine rankings I don't
think this is the most pro-social use of
AI I mean there was a great line from I
think his name is Jeff hammerbacher
who's one of the Cloudera Founders
um I think maybe riffing on Allen on
Ginsburg and he said something like I
saw the best minds of my generation
putting all this effort into selling ads
so like now the best minds are like
putting efforts into writing you know
kind of marginal ad copy and stuff like
that
um I mean you can do that it's a very
suitable application of this technology
what I would like to see people using AI
for is helping in medicine helping build
robots that can take care of the elderly
um you know I've maybe more idealistic
address climate change address climate
change exactly you know I think there
are many problems that AI could really
help Humanity with but the low-hanging
fruit the easy stuff to do is sell ads
and write copy and stuff like that and
that's kind of what you know gpt4 is
good at
thank you
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of gen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who started an app
to solve that are the founders of Bloom
Bloom app is the award-winning Financial
Services app it's made by young people
for young people I've met the founders
they are great guys who want to make you
or the people in your life who are young
and just starting out financially
literate check it out at bloomapp.com
and there's a special offer for
listeners to this podcast 15 in free
stock and one month subscription for
free go to bloomapp.com Yang to sign up
today
bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the dark
in terms of financial literacy let's get
educated people bluemap.com yang
[Music]
thank you
what do you think about having licenses
for AI models I think it's probably a
good idea you I don't know that we need
licenses for everything but even for
research purposes like in Psychology
people have moved towards registering
every experiment and that cleans up the
science if we know what's been done we
have what's called a file drawer problem
where people try and experiment it
doesn't work and then they don't write
about it and then you have 10 people try
it it doesn't work one person tries it
and by some statistical fluke it works
they publish that and then it distorts
the literature so in Psychology and some
other fields medicine people are
starting to go with it into what they
call registered experiments where you
say this is what I'm going to do this is
the methodology and so forth the science
in AI would actually be better off if we
did that and then we get into questions
about like liability and so forth like
if somebody's model gets abused in some
way we'd like to know whose model would
like to be watermarked registered so we
can go fix it we can adapt it and so
forth so there is reason you might
exempt certain things and not big enough
to be relevant something like that but I
think we should move towards that in
general
wow I guess another reason to have this
uh AI agency because it would be
Distributing monitoring uh licenses and
then keeping track of who's doing what
yeah absolutely I think that should be
part of what an agency does is to
license in some cases like if there are
a lot of risks make sure that those
risks have been well thought through if
it's well known stuff it might be a
lighter you know licensing requirement
but if it's something brand new and we
don't understand it then maybe there
should be more serious um you know
analysis before it's it's widely
released what's funny is when I hear
this licensing conversation I probably
just think of driver's tests like the
rest of it's like AI driver's test can
this thing it shouldn't be you know
easier to use an AI system that you
deploy to 100 million people then to get
a license for a car I mean if we're
going to make you take a road test for a
car then if you have something you're
putting out 100 million people let's
just like make sure it's okay that
nobody's gonna die like that's not it's
not a crazy thing to ask you have the
kind of libertarian you know the Techno
Libertarians like Mark Andreessen who
recently blocked me on Twitter who like
can't stand the thought of any
regulation whatsoever but you know we
have regulation for cars and we have
regulation for airplanes and medicine
like with good reason it's certainly
possible to over regulate we need to
worry about regulatory capture we don't
want the companies making all the rules
and keeping everybody out there's lots
of balance to be struck but the idea
that we would have no regulation and no
licensing requirement that's absurd so
you testify the U.S Senate you gave a
TED Talk you've written a series of
op-eds what's next for you in terms of
trying to put humans back in charge of
of this particular technological era set
of developments how can people follow
you and support you because you one
thing I really admire about you is that
you're looking at this you know you're
doing it just because you think it's the
right thing to do
and you're going to keep on finding
levers to pull and people to work with
etc etc what's next for you on this path
and how can people support it I mean
they can read my sub stack I am working
towards maybe launching a non-profit and
I've been talking to some
philanthropists about this that would
help with AI governance by not relying
on governments to get everything
together and offering an alternative
path that maybe I'll talk about sometime
soon I'm not quite ready to develop all
the details but so I I'm I'm thinking
about that people can of course follow
me on Twitter I'm at Gary Marcus the sub
stack is Gary marcus.substack.com and if
people see ways to improve the
governance of AI which is really what
I'm focused on they can reach out I
um also my website has a contact form
garymarcus.com
um and people who have you know real
skills in developing governance and and
so forth you know I'd love some help
do you ever catchy name for the
potential non-profit we have a name I
don't know if it's catchy enough so
people could also help with that with
the the working title is the center for
trustworthy AI very self-evident I do
like obvious names but perhaps there is
some marketing genius in the audience uh
who'll reach out to on Twitter and then
if
their name gets accepted uh they get our
Eternal gratitude and the Gratitude of
humanity
absolutely and mentioned in my sub stack
so
well who could do better than a mention
in Gary's substack uh congratulations
again man for taking on this cause your
voice of reason Humanity moderation when
I say moderation I mean
um like you cut to the truth of things
as opposed to getting caught in the hype
one-way or another I hope that people do
take heed to what you're saying uh you
know you're not
the least bit over dramatic or
Sensational about it and if you're
concerned I think a lot of other people
should be too some of the pitfalls you
describe uh including a
pretty nasty cacophonist disastrous
election cycle in 2024. uh I totally
agree with
I really appreciate your support the
chance to to talk to your audience
um and I mean I think you know you and I
met for the first time a few weeks ago
in New York and it was clear that we
have a kind of common view about trying
to figure out what's best for Humanity
and and really taking that seriously and
not just focusing on our own personal
gain and so no doubt Gary it's going to
take people like you and uh Ian with a
dose of me and hopefully we can leave
this place still in fine shape for
humans like our kids that would be
awesome that's the goal
[Music]
foreign